now we turn to ukraine where the fight
to retake towns held by russia is
pushing farther east in one liberated
city local officials revealed what
residents are calling russian torture
chambers deborah pattas saw them for
herself and we should warn you that some
of the details of her report are quite
disturbing
first came the shelling then the
persecution
it took place here a police station an
idiom used by russian troops as their
headquarters now it's been demand so
that detectives can begin their work
right here is where the torture chambers
apparently were that's what we're going
to see now
russian soldiers slept here ate here and
meted out the terror used to keep
civilians and captured ukrainian
soldiers under control
the dark damp basement is lined with egg
cartons previously used as an
underground police shooting range it was
already soundproof
that meant that screams would be muffled
and around you see the things that they
left behind they look innocuous
but they were deadly weapons of terror
investigators have testimony from
victims that these were wielded as
implements of torture
we can see here some kind of wooden bat
and masks that we understand
were used to asphyxiate victims during
periods of intense torture
unused electric shock devices were also
found
we met torture victim anatoly
last week
who broke down sobbing when he recalled
being electrocuted
prisoners like kharagi were kept in
these cramped cells filled with a stench
of urine from overflowing buckets the
walls peppered with neat rows of pencil
lines one two three four five marking
time prisoners spent locked inside
thirty forty
russian army police chief sergey
bolsonov leads the investigation and we
collect evidence
of fingerprints and dna
from this place from another place in
this building to see if they are alive
or dead of course
he is exhausted already he's cordoned
off more than a dozen crime scenes like
this
russia was trying to strangle local
people he tells us to make them so
scared they'd forget about freedom
but it hasn't worked like so many
ukrainians we've spoken to their spirit
is not broken fear has turned into
defiance michelle
deborah potter thank you in the ukraine